Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Esto puede parecer una pila
de números bien ordenados,
pero en realidad es un tesoro matemático.
Los matemáticos indios la llamaron
escalera del Monte Meru.
En Irán, es el triángulo de Khayyam.
Y en China, es el triángulo de Yang Hui.
Para gran parte del mundo occidental,
se le conoce como el triángulo de Pascal
por el matemático francés Blaise Pascal,
lo que parece algo injusto ya que él
llegó claramente tarde a la fiesta,
pero todavía tenía mucho que aportar.
¿Qué es lo que tiene que ha intrigado
a los matemáticos de todo el mundo?
En resumen,
está lleno de patrones y secretos.
En primer lugar,
está el patrón que lo genera.
Comienza con 1 e imagina 0 invisibles
a cada lado del mismo.
Suma los pares,
para generar la siguiente fila.
Ahora, haz esto una y otra vez.
Sigue adelante y terminarás
con algo como esto,
aunque en realidad el triángulo de Pascal
continúa infinitamente.
Cada fila corresponde a lo que se llama
los coeficientes de un desarrollo binomial
de la forma (x + y) ^ n,
donde n es el número de la fila,
empezando a contar desde cero.
Así que si haces a n = 2 y lo expandes,
te da (x ^ 2) + 2xy + (y ^ 2).
Los coeficientes o números
delante de las variables,
son los mismos que los números
en la fila del Triángulo de Pascal.
Verás lo mismo con n = 3,
que se expande a esto.
El triángulo es una manera rápida y fácil
de consultar todos estos coeficientes.
Pero hay mucho más.
Por ejemplo,
suma los números en cada fila,
y obtendrás sucesivas potencias de 2.
O en una fila trata cada número
como parte de una expansión decimal.
En otras palabras,
la fila dos es (1x1) + (2x10) + (1x100).
Obtendrás 121, que es 11 ^ 2.
Y echa un vistazo a lo que sucede
cuando haces lo mismo a la fila 6.
Suma 1.771.561,
que es 11 ^ 6, y así sucesivamente.
También hay aplicaciones geométricas.
Mira las diagonales.
Las dos primeras poco interesantes:
todos uno, y luego los enteros positivos,
también conocidos como números naturales.
Pero los números en la siguiente diagonal
son llamados los números triangulares
porque al tomar muchos puntos,
puedes apilarlos
en triángulos equiláteros.
La siguiente diagonal
tiene los números tetraédricos
porque del mismo modo, puedes apilar
muchas esferas en tetraedros.
O qué tal esto: sombreado
en todos los números impares.
No parece mucho
con el triángulo pequeño,
pero si se agregas miles de filas,
obtienes un fractal
conocido como triángulo de Sierpinski.
Este triángulo no es solo
un trabajo de arte matemático.
También es muy útil,
especialmente cuando se trata
de probabilidad y cálculos
en el dominio de la combinatoria.
Digamos que quieres tener 5 hijos,
y te gustaría saber la probabilidad
de tener tu familia de ensueño
de 3 niñas y 2 niños.
En la expansión binomial,
corresponde a chica más chico
a la quinta potencia.
Fijémonos en la fila cinco,
donde el primer número
corresponde a 5 chicas,
y el último corresponde a 5 chicos.
El tercer número
es lo que estamos buscando.
10 de la suma de todas
las posibilidades en la fila.
de modo 10/32, o 31,25 %.
O, si estás escogiendo al azar un equipo
de baloncesto de 5 jugadores
de un grupo de 12 amigos,
¿cuántos posibles grupos de 5 hay?
En términos combinatorias, este problema
se expresa como de 12 elegir 5,
y podría calcularse con esta fórmula,
o podrías mirar el sexto elemento
de la fila doce en el triángulo
y obtener tu respuesta.
Los patrones en el triángulo de Pascal
son un testimonio del elegante
entretejido de las matemáticas.
Y todavía está revelando
secretos frescos a hoy.
Por ejemplo, se descubrió
recientemente una manera de ampliarlo
a este tipo de polinomios.
¿Qué podemos encontrar a continuación?
Bueno, eso depende de ti.